just before we get started i do want to
mention another channel that i host
called mega projects mega projects is a
channel all about mega projects
where i take a deep look at incredible
buildings project structures
and more whether it's the world's most
impressive skyscrapers the international
space station or chernobyl sarcophagus
i cover it all new videos come out a
couple of times a week on mega projects
so if you think it could be for you
please do head on over and subscribe
there is a link below and let's get into
it
the whole fabric of america is bloody to
its very core and there's no quicker way
to find out someone shares your
bloodlust than
when the subject of serial killers comes
up think about the recent renaissance of
true crime shows
look at what some of the top rated
podcasts are people
can't get enough murder in their
recreational unwinding time
it's a way of living vicariously and
maybe it's
healthy overall but it's more than a
little dark
serial killers and their tales of
adventure that captivated the public
really seemed to hit a stride in the
1960s
and thereafter the zodiac killer son of
sam edgine
and john wayne gacy kept people glued to
their newspapers and news broadcasts to
see
what awful mesmerizing things they had
done the cities and towns where these
killers operated stayed gripped
in fear during their unpredictable and
sporadic reigns of terror
and that was just as true in the upstate
new york town of rochester
in the early 1970s there between 1971
and 1973
someone was kidnapping children and
murdering them but that's just the
beginning
of the weirdness surrounding these cases
here
today we take a look at the alphabet
murders
[Music]
in the mid-afternoon of november the
16th 1971 ten-year-old carmen colon was
running errands before returning back to
her home in rochester
she made a stop at a pharmacy to pick up
a prescription for her grandmother and
while being informed that the medication
was not yet ready to be picked up
became noticeably distracted and upset
she told the owner of the pharmacy that
she had to go
and she got into a car parked nearby
three hours later she was reported
missing to the rochester police
department
in those few hours between her leaving
the pharmacy and becoming an official
missing person
she was observed at a local interstate
half-naked
and flailing her arms for help a vehicle
identified as a dark-forward pinto was
backing up frantically and trying to run
her down and eventually
an individual overpowered her and threw
her back in the car
about 30 motorists on the highway
witnessed the act
though not one soul attempted to
intervene in the apparent abduction
none of the drivers who saw what
happened even thought
to cool it in until three days later
unfortunately
by that time it was too late on november
the 18th two teenagers came across the
body of carmen colin nearly
12 miles from where she was seen
struggling on the interstate some of her
clothing was in fact found near that
very highway
she had been raped her skull had been
fractured and she had been strangled to
death
local newspapers soon offered up a
meager award for whoever could offer
information leading to an arrest and
some billboards were later erected
asking for clues
the potential suspects that would crop
up after the first murder
only added more perplexing questions to
the case
[Music]
miguel colen was carmen colen's uncle
and after her parents split up he became
even
closer to carmen and her mother when she
would take her usual walks to the
pharmacy she was usually accompanied by
her grandfather felix but on the day of
the disappearance she
somehow persuaded him to let her travel
alone this was the day
that she got into a strange car later on
the highway she was fleeing from what
was presumably the same car
a dark ford pinto hatchback just before
carmen colin went missing her uncle
miguel took possession of a car that
eerily matched the car from the highway
incident when the authorities learned of
this they went to miguel's home to
search the vehicle
during the investigation they took note
of the car having recently been
profusely cleaned especially the trunk
which had been gone over in detail with
a rather strong cleaning product
now if you've paid attention to anyone's
car trunk ever
you'll know that this is a pretty rare
occurrence investigators asked the
dealership if that was a common practice
since
it was a relatively new purchase on
miguel's behalf the dealer stated that
they had not conducted such a cleaning
more creepily a doll of carmen was
found in the car which he explained off
by saying he was a family member and
that it wasn't very strange at all
what was strange however was miguel's
sudden panic two days after carmen's
death in which he allegedly told a
friend that he had to flee the country
because
he had done something wrong in rochester
and indeed he did take off for puerto
rico very soon after
and this isn't the last you'll hear
about miguel colon in this video
on an early april afternoon in 1972 more
than a year
after carmen colen's murder
eleven-year-old wanda wilkowitz was
heading home after an errand much like
carmen had been in her hometown of
rochester just like carmen she was
getting groceries and headed back
down the road towards her house it was 5
15 pm
joyce wander's mother reported her
missing at around 8 pm a slew of
detectives canvassed an enormous area of
land near her home
they scoured the area around the grocery
store they knew she had been at before
her disappearance and
they searched near the local river where
they knew she would sometimes play
rescue teams had a few straggling
reports of wander grocery bags in hand
resting against a fence to
keep herself from dropping the bags as a
dark brown vehicle approached her
at 10 am the next morning a policeman
found her body at the base of a hill
it had been apparently thrown from a
moving car and rolled down to the ground
below
she had been sexually assaulted and
choked to death much like carmen the
previous year
she had fought her attacker which was
clear from the defensive wounds
oddly she had a noticeable amount of
white cat air on her body even though no
family owned such animals
during the autopsy custard was
discovered around her stomach contents
something a family swore she would not
have eaten at home or school
so was her killer feeding her hotlines
were set up much larger rewards of ten
thousand dollars were offered and
tips rolled in from the public one tip
came from someone who said they saw
wander speaking with the driver of that
brown car from the passenger side window
just before she went missing
another tip said they saw a man forcing
a girl matching wander's looks into
a light-colored dodge dart type
automobile flyers were plastered all
over the surrounding neighborhoods in
the hopes that
any shred of evidence would point
investigators in the right direction the
already apparent surface similarities
between carmen and wanda's cases were
almost immediately dismissed by the
local police department more suspects
more tips and even more questions ensued
[Music]
michelle mainzer was returning home from
school on november 26 1973
just about seven months after the murder
of wander walkerbits
the eleven-year-old stopped at a
rochester department store on the way
back attempting to fetch a purse her
mother had left there earlier
her uncle passed her at some points
offering to give her a ride but michelle
opted to go it alone witnesses reported
that soon after she was seen entering a
tan or beige vehicle
this was not her uncle's car her mother
reported her missing that evening
around 4 30 pm a girl who matched
mensa's features was seen eating at a
fast food restaurant with a man
described
as a caucasian between the ages of 25
and 35 and roughly six feet tall or 165
pounds
a person traveling down a nearby road
around 5 30 p.m that day said they saw
the same beige or tan colored vehicle
as earlier in the afternoon but with a
flat tire the motorist also apparently
saw a girl that looked very much like
michelle
and noticed she was in a fair amount of
distress she was being held
by the wrist by the driver outside of
the car and when the approaching witness
tried to stop and check on the girl
he was met with a glare by the suspect
the kidnapper tried to hide the girl
behind him and also attempted to keep
his license plate out of sight
he put off a menacing enough vibe that
the would-be helper drove off
two days later on november 28th michelle
mendes body was found in a ditch roughly
15 miles from her home
just like the first two victims she had
been sexually assaulted and then
strangled with
some kind of rope or cord and just like
wanda wakowitz she had
numerous strands of white cat hair on
her some small samples of prince and
semen were
able to be recovered and upon autopsy
her stomach contents included traces of
hamburger backing up the story of her
last being seen at a fast food
restaurant a composite sketch of the man
who was seen with her was circulated but
like most of the tiny nuggets of
possible leads that crept up through the
case
real concrete information was not to be
had
[Music]
so why were these dubbed the alphabet
murders well you may have noticed that
all three victims had
first and last names that started with
the same letter as time has gone on
experts think the likelihood that this
was intentional
is very low but even if the killer had
chosen his victims on this basis
that's not even the strangest of the
similarities in the crimes there's the
final resting place of each body
all three children were from rochester
but when their bodies were discovered it
was in a different town and each town
corresponded to their names
carmen colon's body was found in the
town of churchville
wando aquits was seven miles away from
rochester in the town of webster
and michelle manza was found in mason
while you could argue that the names
were coincidences it's hard to argue
that the killer didn't somehow plan to
dump each victim in a place
that matched their name lettering
there's also the obvious fact that each
of the victims was a pre-teen girl
they all disappeared during rainy days
were of short height and were all seen
as loner types without many close
friends
the positioning of each body when they
were found seemed to point to them all
being thrown from a vehicle
each girl was brought up in a poor
catholic family and had history with
being bullied and
having issues with academic performance
in school which gave investigators some
inkling that
the murderer may have had a background
in social services and
thus had access to knowing these very
specific details about the girls
miguel colon as we mentioned spirited
away to puerto rico four short days
after his niece was killed
in march of 1972 investigators made
their way down there to begin
asking him questions about her
disappearance and murder the fact that
he had a car that resembled the one seen
during the time of carmen's kidnapping
and the suspicious extent which the
vehicle had been
cleaned gave them plenty of suspicion
however down in puerto rico newspapers
caught wind of the authority's desire to
interview him and
published articles that miguel saw
causing him to flee he did return later
in march and was extradited back to new
york state
during questioning miguel was not able
to provide a sufficient excuse for where
he was during carmen's disappearance
and has no other people who could back
him up regarding his location that day
despite strong suspicion that they had
their guy in the end
there was no physical evidence that
could definitively link him or his car
to the crimes in 1991 20 years after his
niece was killed miguel took his own
life after being involved in a dispute
at home where he shot his brother
and his wife the good samaritan who
tried to approach the individual who had
captured michelle mainzer was a bit of
help
even though the kidnapper tried to block
him from seeing his license plate that
person was able to read off a partial
plate to the authorities
as luck would have it he ran across the
same car several days later and was able
to provide the full license plate number
this led police to a man living with his
family in lyons new york just over 40
miles from rochester this new suspect
had a beige-colored sedan a strong
resemblance to witness sketches and
had been in trouble with the law for
petty crimes for quite a while his alibi
to the police was that he had been out
looking for work that entire day upon
further investigation and
perusing phone records it seemed that
his alibi was airtight
he even passed a polygraph the suspect
never had his name released and even
though he might have been the closest
the police got to a real lead
he never panned out dennis termini was
another potential lead in the alphabet
murders
a local firefighter in the rochester
area tomini was also known
as the garage rapist and had raped at
least 14 females between the years of
1971 and 1973
which are the years that the alphabet
murders occurred termini owned a
beige-colored car which was the color of
vehicle that had been seen at more than
one of the abductions
he also resided on the street very close
to the area where witnesses last
reported seeing michelle mainzer
mainzer was thought to be the last
victim of the alphabet murders but five
weeks after her death dennis tamini
tried to pull a gun on a teenage girl
with the intent of abducting her she
started screaming which
led him to flee the scene but he
obviously didn't learn his lesson and
tried again soon after to kidnap another
girl
police were made aware and started after
him domini was not going to be captured
alive and
so he shot himself in the head years
later forensic studies were conducted
with termini's exhumed corpse
they compared dna from his body to semen
samples that were saved from wander
awkwards
nothing matched unfortunately no
evidence was available from michelle
mains body the
one victim they had him most closely
tied to his car however had all sorts of
white cat hair on the surfaces within
and as we know white cat air was found
on two of the alphabet victims
then there's kenneth bianchi who drew
police interest because he lived and
worked near the first two murder
locations he held jobs as an ice cream
man a security guard and an ambulance
driver which made investigators think he
wore many uniforms that
would make children approach him and
trust him he too had a car that matched
the description
passed around as being near the scenes
of the alphabet abductions bianca moved
to california in 1976
three years after the last killing he
and his cousin became serial killers on
the west coast known as the hillside
strangler
between 1977 and 1978 they murdered 10
females between the ages
of 12 and 28 though bianca strongly
denies having anything to do with the
alphabet murders
yet another subject was joseph nasso who
did his own series of killings in
california between 1977 and 1994. his
victims were mostly believed to be
prostitutes but
one interesting detail that came up was
that all the females he killed had
first and last names that began with the
same letter just like the alphabet
murders
nasa was also a rochester new york
native and lived there in the early
1970s
in fact he often traveled back and forth
between new york and california
and this wasn't lost on investigators
the same samples they tested from wanda
wawakowitz's body
against dennis tamini were tested
against naso's dna
and they did not match naeso was
convicted of his own california alphabet
murders however and was sentenced to
death in 2013.
when police searched his house more
thoroughly they found an absolutely
insane journal where nasa kept the
details of his murders
[Music]
obviously the alphabet murders remain
unsolved to this day little pieces of
evidence
have pointed to many potential suspects
but none of it has been
indisputable enough to land a conviction
it's not even truly known if all three
murders
are definitely connected tips rolled in
from the public and new suspects had a
brief light shined on them but
then something wouldn't connect a
polygraph would pass or
an alibi would line up did joseph naso
merely move to california and
continue killing their retaining the
alphabet method
was it someone else entirely and they
just moved somewhere else and killed
there
did they feel like the law was closing
in after the third murder and they
somehow quelled the urge to kill again
there are so many questions and zero
sense of closure for the families
even the experts have a hard time
drawing conclusions
one such expert was robert ressler who
actually came up with the term serial
killer and who spent
decades profiling them and trying to get
inside their heads
wrestler worked at the fbi in the
behavioral sciences unit
where he got to examine the actions and
thoughts of some of the most horrid
people
that ever lived wrestler actually did
not believe that the same person
conducted all three killings
when you drop profiles of the killers he
believed that carmen's killing showed
a much higher level of anger and
aggression she also had not received
food before her death like the other two
girls seemingly did
finally the killer choked her with his
hands whereas wander and michelle had
ligatures used on them
the experts also seemed to believe that
the matching first and last initials of
each victim was purely coincidence they
believed that the level of thought
required organizational skill that the
killer simply did not have
the murders the brutal dumping of the
bodies and even the kidnappings
themselves had no methodical
orchestration to them
is it possible that the killer's trial
run with carmen didn't go according to
plan and
that he got better at his work with the
next two of course
we just can't say
[Music]
the new york state police city of
rochester police and two neighboring
county departments all still have open
cases for the girls who were killed the
departments
still work closely together and meet to
discuss new details when they come up
new technology being much more advanced
than what was available in the 1970s
they are now able to test genetics and
swap for dna to create new suspects or
eliminate past ones
databases are available to instantly
access information from decades ago
the original detectives meet with the
new guard to pick each other's brains
and share leads
they all share the same sense of wanting
to honor the memories of the girls and
help the families close a door that's
been maddeningly left open
for so long carmen colon wanda akowitz
and michelle maynard
all share the same cemetery in rochester
as their final resting place
so i'm not going to ask whether you
enjoyed that video but i do hope you
found it interesting at least if you did
please do hit that like button below
don't forget to subscribe
as always thank you for watching
[Music]
you